When I give £10 in charity and it is
consumed, the rewards come to an end.
However, if I give to a wak, then you've
put your money into something permanent.
It's a endowment that continues to give
on your behalf until the day you meet
Allah subhana wa tala. Subhan Allah.
That is
amazing. I legacy brothers and sisters.
We want you to build a legacy with your
saddaka. Where will your donation be
going? events, global events inspiring
the iman of millions around the world.
Education, free Quran lessons, free
lectures, free reminders. Number three,
media content for kids, educational
shows, spiritual Islamic shows online,
brothers and sisters. Go to the link
inshallah and donate in this bless 10
days inshallah. May Allah bless you
guys. Asalam alalaykum.
five or four or five things that Ronaldo
has been doing lately and especially
what happened yesterday which shows a
clear sign of him he must accept Islam.
Let's watch in so this is Ronaldo making
dua but besides his dua there's free
four other stuff that he's been doing. I
don't know if you guys have noticed um
that show indicates that he is most
likely a Muslim. Here's one of them.
Ronaldo was seen making dua, hands
raised, whispering, uttering something
and displaying signs of extreme
desperation and eyes looking above at
times. Dua, we make dua like this. The
Christians don't make dua like this. The
Jews don't make dual like this. The
Hindus don't make dua like this. The
Siks don't make dua like this. The
Buddhists don't make dua like this. Uh,
nobody makes dual like this sisters. The
Muslims make prayer dua like this.
Number one, this shows an action that
it's not something new. It's not he
didn't go from doing this to this. No,
there was it was an immediate action.
meaning he's done it before. So this is
a great sign that shows that it is and
not only that Allahh says in the Quran
that Allah respond to the caller that
response that calls upon him meaning a
non-Muslim doesn't say a Muslim. Yes,
some could read it as that but it
doesn't mean that because Allah also
tells us in the Quran that when they're
sailing in this boat in the mush and
when they are stuck and there's storms
and stuff like who do they turn to? They
turn to Allah subhanaa tala and Allah
says we answer their prayers and when
they come to the land safely they go
back to their polytheism to their shik.
So subhan Allah it shows that Allah does
can answer the the the prayer genuine
prayer of an atheist whoever exactly
when they directly turn to God Almighty.
That's number one. Here's number two.
Has shown a strong interest in Islam in
recent years and has even performed some
Islamic actions. Number two him doing of
this is something the prophetam done and
you can do it when you've got happy news
etc whatever for that matter and you can
do it without facing the is the sun of
the prophetam. Mate Alwal has revealed
his interest in Islam and how he would
ask teammates to take time out of
training to pray. Number three, his
friends and colleagues saying that he
has interest in Islam that there's
rumors now there's rumors about his
conversion or his clothes and this
happened at the time of prophetam
certain individuals who were like they
showed signs you know he showed signs
when he was had when the prophetam was
beaten by Abu Jah may Allah curse him
and Hamza smacked his face and said now
I accept Islam even though he genuinely
did not believe it but there was signs
he said it out of anger but then he
ultimately came for real this though did
so did you see that come Come here.
Please come here. You're going to help
him. Did you see that uh LeBron played
with his son again? You're going to
you're going to recreate that with your
father. You are.
Okay. His son says inshallah. Now, this
is something like you said, kids copy.
Like when I pray, my children copy my
2-year-old, my four-year-old, you know,
they they copy what I do. They say
things what I say. So, subhan, that
shows that this is something
incorporated in the house, you know, and
we've heard him say inshallah as well
before, you know, with etc. So, that's
number four. That's a great sign as
well. Number five, if you give the God
going to give you the double. So this is
what's happened in my
life. Since I start to do that,
everything in my life become better and
better. So I will still carry on to do
that. Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said, charity does not decrease
wealth. He's saying the saying of the
prophetam saddaka will never make you
poor. He's basically saying not only
he's embodied it, nobody not only he's
seen it the is true that when you give
in charity, Allah will give you more.
He's saying, behaving, actions, rumors,
um, dua, saga, these are all clear signs
he is a Muslim. It's going to be a
matter of time. He's going to declare
shahada and he's going to tell us that I
accept I've been a Muslim for a couple
of years because how could one do these
actions, know about these things, say
these things, and we judge a person by
their actions as well. Now, of course,
for faith to be accepted that you have
to, somebody that believes in his heart
but doesn't testify in his tongue is
known as a disbeliever. Yes. And this
changes. It can be someone that knows
it's the truth but is not reject
rejecting for whatever reason. Or
someone can be just like they're a bit
cautious. They still want to know that's
a different story. For someone that
testifies on their tongue but doesn't
believe in their heart they are a
monafic. Yes. But to me inshallah we
assume the best that there is no doubt
Ronaldo is a Muslim. No doubt. And the
fact that you're making a dua as a
non-Muslim you're watching this you can
do the same. Pray to the one true
almighty that has no partner. Not a
mother or a father or daughter or son.
the one true God in Islam that is Allah
subhana wa ta'ala yes he's not a man
he's not a woman worship him alone
inshallah and talking about guys please
support the da project inshallah that IM
legacy is doing and you can help
millions and thousands of people to
learn about Islam to accept Islam says
it is a that is a that carries on giving
long when you have gone away inshallah
brother and sisters make a dua for
Ronaldo his family I believe he's a
Muslim I genuinely believe he's a Muslim
inshallah and I believe he's already
testified it and it is keeping on the
low inshallah may Allah subhanaa tala
guide him and that's how Allah works
when you are sincere when you are
genuine Allah will take you to places
and you will accept inshah the Islam
inshallah just like the Italian man at
daw table you can watch at the end of
the video inshallah there'll be a little
box an Italian man a sincere man who
came to his table and said his wife was
stopping him from accepting Islam he
took the shahad what sincere man you can
watch that video on my new channel raw
till next Asalam allayikum.